[Musique]
mes chers amis
bonsoir et bien c'est depuis l'alhambra
maurice chevalier à paris que nous vous
présentons ce soir notre émission le bon
numéro et mes chers amis
rompant avec sept ans de tradition de
télé match et bien non ce soir vous ne
verrez pas de candidat sur la scène de
l'alhambra
non les candidats ce sera vous vous qui
me regardent et actuellement devant
votre écran de télévision
vous tous qui êtes là dans cette salle
et qu'ils allaient jouer avec nous au
bon numéro pour gagner les dix mille
nouveaux francs 1 millions d'anciens
francs qui sont offertes par la loterie
nationale
c'est extrêmement ça il n'est nul besoin
de connaissances particulières un peu
d'astuce un peu d'attention et je crois
que tout se passera bien pauvre alors si
vous le voulez bien nous allons tout
d'abord vous présentez un peu le
mécanisme de cette émission est tout
d'abord et bien la comptabilité de
l'émission et pour cela vous allez avoir
absolument besoin de ces cases qui vont
s'allumer derrière mans
[Musique]
les voilà toutes les vitres à lui mais
oui le bon numéro se compose de huit
chiffres 1 2 points 4 5 6 7 8 8 chiffres
que vous allez devoir trouver en
regardant notre émission effectivement
il y a huit tableaux dans cette émission
et chaque tableau vous permettra de vie
n'est qu'un chiffre mais est il permis
de commencer tout de suite et de
regarder notre première semaine
[Musique]